I’ve been using Apple’s AirPods for over
two years and I love them, and now Apple has
released the updated AirPods with the new
H1 chip, which actually DOES make AirPods
work better and more reliably.
That same chip is packed into the Powerbeats
Pro, which is awesome!
On top of that, the Powerbeats actually get
physical controls, including a more reliable
physical button to pause, switch tracks and
use Siri if you don’t want to use the new
Hey Siri feature.
It also gets something that I really, truly
wish the AirPods had, volume controls on the
earphones themselves, and it’s in a pretty
convenient location as well.
Unlike the AirPods, the Powerbeats wrap around
your ear so they don’t budge at all no matter
what kind of activity you’re doing, but
in most cases, the AirPods won’t fall out
either.
The wrap around design is mostly to keep in
flow with their previous earphones.
One thing I did notice was that the Powerbeats
Pro were nowhere near as comfortable in your
ears as the AirPods over long periods of time.
Your ears actually start to get a bit tired
over time and that doesn’t happen with the
AirPods.
It’s also much quicker and easier to get
the AirPods in your ears.
The Powerbeats Pro definitely require a bit
more work get wrapped around your ears and
may take some time to get used to.
Now the sound quality is noticeably better
on the Powerbeats Pro.
Unlike AirPods, they create a seal inside
of your ear so they sound louder, block out
background noise and there’s much more bass.
Like MUCH more.
Seriously, if you really love bass, just pay
the extra cash for the Powerbeats Pro.
Now are they the best sounding wireless earphones
you can buy at the $250 price point?
No, definitely not, you can probably find
better-sounding ones for a lower price, but
it doesn’t matter because there’s something
missing with the other guys, that beautiful
Beats logo.
Over the years, Beats by Dre has made a name
for itself by creating beautifully designed,
high-quality headphones with great audio quality,
and almost everyone knows that.
Yes, you can go on Amazon and research for
hours trying to find better-sounding earphones
for a cheaper price, but with Beats, you can
trust that they’re gonna work great and
sound great, and that’s why you’ll pay
extra for them.
Not only that, but people around you know
that Beats are expensive, and if you’re
wearing them, it means you’re doing well
financially, and that’s why Beats will have
no problem selling these.
However, you also get that same effect with
the AirPods, so what’s ultimately going
to happen is that Apple fans will buy the
AirPods and Beats fans will buy the PowerBeats
Pro.
Now, what if you like both?
Well, let’s look at the downsides of the
PowerBeats.
The biggest downside is the massive case,
just look at how much larger it is than the
AirPods case, and even at that size, it still
doesn’t include wireless charging.
Why?
Well I think it’s because they’d have
to charge $300 for it, and that can make even
Beats fans think twice.
The tiny AirPods case is incredibly convenient
because you can easily fit it in your pocket
and take it anywhere, but with the PowerBeats
Pro, the case is so huge that it’s really
impractical to squeeze into your pocket and
carry around.
But on the plus side, the battery life on
the Powerbeats Pro lasts 9 hours compared
to 5 with AirPods, so you don’t have to
pop them back into the case for charging quite
as often, so you can leave the case behind.
And when you do have to charge them, a quick
5-minute charge gets you one and a half hours
of playback.
Another minor drawback is that you can only
charge the case using a Lightning cable, which
isn’t as widely available as USB-C, but
the case itself holds 15 hours of extra juice,
just like the AirPods.
I also noticed another small issue with the
Powerbeats.
With the AirPods, you can easily flick open
the top with one hand while you put your AirPods
back with the other.
With PowerBeats Pro, you’ll have to use
both hands to get it open.
That may sound a little farfetched but these
are the little differences you’ll notice
daily.
With that said, the Powerbeats Pro are still
excellent earbuds that are a little on the
pricey side thanks to that Beats by Dre badge.
If you like long battery life, physical controls,
and great-sounding bass, you’ll love these
earphones.
Now if you prefer comfort and convenience
and saving some cash, I think you’ll be
very happy with the AirPods.
If you enjoyed this review, tap that like
button and click that circle above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video.